mike vit dans la rue depuis un an mais
sera annoncée dans des erreurs de
parcours le plus tendus david a pas aidé
non plus au deuxième confinement le je
me suis planté comme vous
monsieur hamon cnra source c'est à
longuet nous sommes devant le refuge de
l'église notre dame de grâce à longueuil
une vingtaine de personnes en situation
d'itinérance espère obtenir un lit pour
la nuit qui viennent la gagne qu'on y 7
ha soit l'eia ne vaut mais risqué
métier-là cas où la moitié qui remporte
la map à deux places dormait ce soir cet
homme qui refuse d'être identifiée
attend lui aussi une place pour la nuit
je tombais mal à vin 2009 puis j'étais
là j'avais un commerce avec eux des gens
polis john ami ma femme est partie avec
un doute n'agissent les 20 15 heures
puis je vous en mets tabou chez les
minimes ils se cachent tout est
tellement cher je me serais mons et les
rues selon la tabac d'itinérance de la
rive sud il y avait environ 70 itinérant
à longueuil avant la pandémie et bien ce
nombre maintenant doublé installer des
nouveaux services
d'hébergement d'urgence à longueuil une
organiste s'appelle la halte du coin qui
s'est développée pendant ta copine puis
bon on avait
placé dans une église puis jour en
personne puis après quelques jours
c'était rempli à pleine capacité à 25
puis depuis sa pole en chine plusieurs
candidats et candidates dans la campagne
électorale municipale à longueuil ont
suggéré des propositions pour venir en
aide à ces personnes mais du côté des
organismes communautaires et bien la
confiance n'y est pas un truc sont élus
ben
et on pense à l'action c'est ce qui nous
inquiète après parce que je veux un des
enjeux qu'on a du côté de toutes les
ressources et la cohabitation avec la
population générale à laval une nouvelle
unité mobile vient d'être mise en
service pour les itinérants parce que là
aussi le nombre de personnes en
situation d'itinérance a presque doublé
les gens nous arrive avec des problèmes
plus lourd plus complexe et qui
demandent des solutions beaucoup plus
globale boom est arrivée la pandémie qui
est hautement fragilisé des personnes et
nos services bien sûr et on a vu une
augmentation du nombre de personnes qui
devenir visibles et comme à longueuil
les organismes en itinérance soit des
engagements fermes de la part des
candidats et candidates on a rencontré
les principales formations politiques
qui ont pris des engagements plus ou
moins solide selon les candidats et
candidates mais on observe une véritable
préoccupation mais que ce soit à laval
ou à longueuil les besoins en itinérance
sont de plus en plus grands y'a pas
saisir passé de ressources ont des
ressources qu après 120 si je regarde ce
qui donne comme répond
mme diana farrell et jacquemin flux des
poubelles issigeac bissonnet
radio-canada à longueuil